in today's video we're going to be
taking this interior design concept and
create it in our CAD 26. what's going on
guys my name is David Thomas I'm a
registered architect here in Western
Australia and like I mentioned today I'm
going to be walking you through step by
step exactly how you can replicate this
in archicad so let's turn around to this
screen and get started with today's
tutorial Okay so we've got an arcad 26
template open in front of us just use
any template that is available to you
guys we're going to be replicating this
image right here and basically making it
as quickly and as easily as we possibly
can so let's start off by using our wall
tool and coming up and selecting our
wall type because we're focusing on the
internals of the wall it doesn't really
matter too much but let's just pick this
50 millimeter double plaster wall all
I'm going to do is simply draw a 5 meter
by five meter box and use that as my
starting point zooming back in we can
see we have our five by five what we
want to do is actually start using some
furniture pieces to identify spaces as
best we can so let's go into our object
tool and come to the top to open up the
settings we want to search for our first
toilet because the toilet's on the left
it is one of the easiest to use so let's
use arcad 26 wall toilet and adjust our
settings to suit we don't want the
system we actually want it to be an
in-wall mounted carrier unit so we get
that beautiful flush plate the actual
toilet unit itself as well is quite ugly
by default so let's pick something like
toilet type 7. now we want to come
across in our settings and just change a
few bits and pieces first of all we want
to change this to Black to make sure it
isn't a ugly pink color and then we want
to come to our little 3D settings we
want to make our actual toilet a nice
color so the seat is going to be ceramic
porcelain as well the button looks like
it's going to be brass so typing in
metal brass and the connection we
actually want to turn off so if we keep
going through our settings we can turn
our water connection off now last but
not least this isn't an important step
for us now but it is something to always
be AI flub in the future and that's
simply what layer it is on so the toilet
should be on MEP plumbing and then we
can go ahead and press OK we can drop
our toilet in on the side here anywhere
and then come back into our object to
find our shower tool typing in shower
I'm simply just going to use the shower
tray I'm not actually going to use
anything else this is just for a
placeholder so if we go 1200 by 1200
we're going to be able to delete this
later again simply just a placeholder
we're going to be using all of these
objects over here basically from Twin
motion rather than from our cat itself
last but not least we want to come back
into our objects and find a beautiful
little hand Basin so if we type in
vanity we can select Basin 26 and go to
rectangular then we can work through all
of these settings to find exactly what
we're looking for so that's a much nicer
single tap lever again we want to change
that to Black pen so we don't have to
see that ugly purple we want to change
our tap to Brass to match all of our
other fixtures and and then we want to
work through some of these actual
settings as well so for instance this is
only 135 millimeters deep looking at
this image that's easily closer to 200
millimeters it's quite deep and quite
chunky so pressing OK once again
dropping that in there we have our three
spaces created very very quickly next
what I'm going to do is select one of
these outside Leafs command or control D
run it across all the way to the end and
press D again to Dimension this I want
to make these spaces about 1200 wide
each so let's go three six and then tap
the minus button to allow our CAD to
automatically do the mouse for you
holding the command button and clicking
on the two edges is going to allow us to
trim everything off inside so now we're
just going to reposition these the
easiest way for me to do this is simply
creating an arch tool going out typing
600 pressing OK and then aligning three
circles to each wall so that's going to
be the foundation of my arches and all
of this is simply going to be cavity
space I'm going to select my Plumbing
fixtures move them out ever so slightly
now we have to create these curved walls
on the outside so what I'm thinking is
they're going to be about 100
millimeters thick so that means I have
to actually select these circles and
extend them 50 millimeters each so let's
bring this up to 650 and do the same for
this opposite wall here last but not
least we also want to do the same to our
final which unfortunately means we then
also have to just simply adjust our
walls back out then we can come into our
wall tool I'm simply going to select the
generic wall shell go command T open up
the settings convert it to a very basic
structure and then I'm going to reduce
it to 100 millimeters I'm not going in
too much detail with any of that stuff
today we're just making it a simple
internal 3D next we're going to press Ok
We're going to make sure that we've
selected the curved methodology at the
top here we're going to find the center
of our first Circle extend all the way
across and then simply draw half an arc
press command or control D tap the alt
button and repeat that same step so I
have it three times over now I can go
ahead and delete my arches because I
don't need them anymore I can position
these circles exactly where I need them
to be now what you'll notice is these
appear to extend ever so slightly out a
little bit so what I'll do is simply add
an extra 250 ml to each of these edges
so I'm going to create one straight line
copy and paste that across and there we
go now we've got some deeper arches to
actually utilize what you'll also notice
is that our sink has a low wall
approximately here so if we select that
command T we don't want to link that at
all it looks like it is about 900
millimeters so we're going to tap okay
make that a low wall push our hand Basin
to the center and then simply reduce the
width of our hand base into 600. I know
this is going to be my shower point so I
can easily delete my shower which was my
placeholder and then finally I'm going
to hold the old button to use the
eyedropper tool of that low wall and
then replicate it in the toilet space as
well tap the P button to flip that wall
the right way around and then move our
toilet to the center looking at this
picture the toilet's only sticking out
ever so slightly so I'm going to push
that back type 100 type minus and then
readjust our low wall if I select my
Marquee tool and then select just half
this bathroom right click show marking
in 3D we can see we're starting to
create something very quickly and very
easily obviously there's no colors
there's no textures there's nothing
added to this just yet but we're getting
there very quickly what I want to do now
is Select my hand base and drop that
down to the top of the 900. come back
into my ground floor plan tap escape a
couple times and go to my slab tool I
want my slab tool to be able to create
these two Stone bench tops for the
toilet and the Hand Basin so what we're
going to do is simply select our
polygonal method change our slab and tap
the command T again let's change that
down to what looks like a 20 mil Stone
change our materials while we're at it
all to Stone so we're going to use a
white stone marble for this one and
press ok then all we have to do is
simply click around to form our slab so
now that I've done both I can come back
into my 3D Marquee you can see that
we've created our Stone tops what you'll
also notice is that our flush plate is
way too high and our toilet is also way
too high so let's drop that back down to
zero so it isn't floating 100
millimeters above the ground open up our
settings go back to our flush plate and
reduce our carrier height to 750 so now
we have our flush plate mounted on this
wall we can probably even push that up
to 850 if we really like and come back
to our ground floor plan finally what
I'm going to do is go to my slab tool
press command and down arrow turn my
footings on and just drop that to minus
172. press OK right click on our ground
floor show us Trace and simply create a
floor for this project I'm going to go
command T to open this up we're going to
be using tiles rather than any marble it
looks like they're 300 by 300 tiles but
I like 600 they're quite nice and
significantly easy to keep clean so
pressing OK back to Marquee check what
we've created our floor is way too high
so command d drop that down and we're
starting to get the general shape next
what we want to do is actually create
these tiles so the tiles don't go all
the way to the top of our Waters which
makes it a little bit more challenging
first of all let's select all of our
walls that we've created press the
command and G button to group them
command T to open them up and then we're
going to Simply paint them green so in
this instance I'm just going to go paint
forest green link all of them together
press OK and then I can adjust this in
Twin motion again if I double click on
my ground floor plan what I can then do
is once again go to my wall tool use
that generic structure command T drop
that down to own 10 millimeters and then
change the surfaces to a very very
simple tile so it doesn't matter which
tile I'm using because I'm going to
change it in a twin motion again so
let's just simply go tile matte white 15
by 15 link them all together press ok
then all we need to do is Click through
around the edge of these walls to
actually create our two one tiles once
we've completed that for Loop let's come
back into our 3D Marquee and I'm going
to extend these two to one and press OK
it appears that our walls for instance
aren't actually as high as I've created
them so I'm going to select them all
drop that down not linked and let's drop
that to seven so what I've also noticed
is I've pushed these walls a little bit
too close to the other wall so I'm going
to come back in and make sure that my
tiles have been created properly there
we go now that we've fixed up that
little glitch and push these tiles just
a tiny bit away from this wall we've
created exactly what we're looking for
we'll also notice that there's a nice
little trim on the corners here we can
do this number of ways is but the
easiest is simply re-grab our wall open
up the default go to two millimeters
because it's probably going to be some
sort of metal change it to Brass press
OK and then we're just going to create a
five millimeter Corner running both ways
so if we create a little triangle just
like that we can duplicate that to all
the walls that we require we go coming
back into our 3D Marquee you can see
we've got that corner protection on for
all of our tiles and we've created most
of our scene already last but not least
we simply need two more things so let's
come back into our ground floor plan
let's go to our window tool
open up our window settings find a
simple arched window similar to the one
in the actual photo change our materials
across to Black drop our seal down to
900 to match where we've actually
created these low walls increase our
over height to 5 and potentially our
overall width to 1500
then press OK drop that window roughly
next to this space here now because
we've created an extra Leaf of this
small tile wall we'll also need to a
actually introduce an opening so if we
come back into our window tool use our
Arch top opening make sure it's 1500
2100 900 silt press OK and align that
with our window I'm back into our 3D
Marquee I've definitely overdone the
maths on this window so let's reduce
that window back down to 1500 to 1700
and let's reduce the width back down to
maybe 1200 I then also need to repeat
those same steps for the actual cutout
that I've created now last but not least
we also need a ceiling so we can select
our slab command D press the alt button
or option button drag it all the way to
the top and change the material to
plasterboard pressing OK we now have
most of our bathroom created so what I'm
going to do is come to my grant floor
plan zoom out 3D Marquee a lot more of
this space right click show is marquee
so now we can actually utilize most of
this bathroom space and actually take it
into twin motion to render it out
properly if you've been paying close
attention throughout the tutorial you
would have noticed this desk mat on the
desk right there basically what it is is
an archicad tutorials shortcut desk mat
it features all the shortcuts you need
to make your workflow faster better and
simply easier every single time without
having to remember hundreds and hundreds
of shortcuts the shortcuts come in three
colors and also for PC and Mac so if you
want to grab yours today make sure you
check out davidtomage.com in the
description down below okay so now what
we've done is we've taken that our CAD
model converted it into twin motion so
we can start adding some of these
beautiful fixtures colors and trims so
let's start off with the actual green
itself because that is a horrendous ugly
green and I don't want to look at it
let's go into our Mega scans Library
let's go to surfaces plaster painted so
I'm going to start by using this stud Co
facade because it has a light gray
undertone texture so we can change it to
that green color quite easily if we go
to our color and ever so slightly start
adjusting we'll find our pale green
color relatively quickly this is what
I'm going to be using for the time being
if you want to copy that code right
there you're more than welcome to
replicate the same image otherwise we
can keep adjusting and playing until
we're closer to the actual color itself
so that's the final code press OK and
let's go back to our main library now
we're going to go into materials metal
and I'm going to Simply drag and drop
the brass onto our two finishes I'm
going to reduce my reflectivity a little
bit open up the color as well and turn
it more into an orangey brass rose gold
final finish and press OK next we're
going to go back into our Mega scans go
to surfaces scroll until we hit tiles go
to our ceramic tiles and see if we can
find these very modern very trendy white
square tiles so this ceramic tile here
looks quite similar Let's test it out
see if it's the right one for this
project it doesn't look too bad but we
do want to adjust some of the features
so let's make that fully reflective
let's try introduce a bit more of a blue
tinge to turn it to more of a natural
white color based on the reflection of
the sun itself press OK dive further
into our scale settings go into our axes
and start reducing the stretch itself so
now I think that a 2 on The X and 1.75
on the Y is appropriate and then I'm
simply just going to move it up ever so
slightly on the y-axis to remove that
last tile cut off so it's very clean
then I'm going to come back into my
library materials let's go into wall
coverings drag and drop a plaster onto
our actual ceiling adjust our color
again let's drag that more into the blue
space to make it more white and clean
rather than yellow because we've got a
Morning Sun happening press OK increase
our reflectiveness ever so slightly and
then back into Mega scans surfaces we're
going to scroll down to our marble find
the tile that is most comparable to what
we see on the screen so I've decided on
this white marble tile here so I'm going
to scale this up to two and I'm going to
introduce a bit more of a gray tinge to
this color so dragging that down making
them a little bit gray more towards our
white polished floor so let's introduce
a bit more of a pinky undertone press
okay I'm going to increase the
reflectiveness of them as well to start
seeing more of our shadows and more
about City skyscraper Skyline in this
final render then we're going to go back
to library go to sketchfab and start
looking for our final finishing touches
so we have a pendant light a mirror a
shower head and Rose and our Channel
drain as well that we need to add so I'm
going to go through these quickly and
jump back into it when I've found all
the right objects there we go we've
managed to find all of our materials or
create something from scratch so
basically what we've done is we've used
a plain one meter wide basic object from
Twin motion put a grid texture over the
top we've introduced small coat hooks a
now the shower head the shower mixer as
well as a handheld holder unfortunately
I wasn't actually able to find the whole
hose itself but what I did find was a
chamfered box along with a custom
texture over the top to make that
replica of this Timber obviously we
could have done this in our CAD a lot
better and a lot quicker but overall I
think that works for the time being what
I had to do with this globe as well was
create a sphere one meter and then also
replicate a pendant over the top so this
sphere basically just sits over top of a
white pendant and gives it a bit more
color and reliability based on the
original image that we're trying to
replicate all we need to do now is put
together some 3D videos export it and
we're completely done
foreign
that's all for me today guys thank you
so much for watching I hope you enjoyed
the video if you did make sure you check
out the playlist inside of me for more
great architectural content if you love
the video make sure you smash that
subscribe button down below hit the like
button and if you have any questions
make sure you leave a comment as well
but like I mentioned that is all from me
so I'll see you next Monday